I'm all for companies doing their best
to be a force for good and I applaud
efforts companies like sky and many
others have made when it comes to
initiatives like removing plastic
however a sane company seems to be
taking their quest for good a little far
we work a co-working company with some
200,000 members and 6,000 staff have
decided to ban meet yes from now on
citing environmental reasons they will
no longer be providing meat at any
events and will not pay for meats in
employee expenses sure serve me my drink
in a non disposable cup give me recycled
hand towels and metal cutlery but
telling me what to eat yet sorry we work
but for me that wouldn't work yeah
there's a moment I agree with you
there's a moment when you say hang on I
am an individual I'm entitled to make
these decisions for myself I mean I live
with someone who is a doesn't eat meat
at all I'm Mike lesioning my kids don't
eat meeting increasingly I feel like a
pariah to sit here so get a get a steak
and cook it for myself and I do feel
that there's a fundamental change coming
on but but I do I agree with you I don't
think someone should say to you know you
can't have this I'm your employer you
can't have this but to be fair but what
they do say I'll show you what they do
say is they say that this policy will
save more than 445 million pounds of
carbon dioxide emissions sixteen point
six billion gallons of water and more
than fifteen and a half million animals
now I don't quite get the third one I
mean those animals won't be born if
they're not going to be because that's
the words well they're bred
we're always some governments companies
everybody you're always weighing up on
you the rights of the individual versus
what's for the what you consider for the
good of society you're involved in
businesses would you ever tell your
employees you can't eat meat
oh I won't pay for me in expenses no but
I I think they're perfectly entitled to
say when we are organizing an event yeah
for our staff we don't supply that I
think that's perfectly valid being on I
mean that's what they're doing so
they're not saying if you work for us
you are never allowed to eat meat thing
we will not use our money to pay for you
to eat me discrimination business is
entitled to design its expenses policy
is going to be I mean you're lucky you
get expensive you are of the private
conversation how can you tolerate such
intolerance it's not intolerant somebody
who likes a steak or chicken right to
have lunches on expenses my lawyer gives
that's something thick no no there's a
joke about to speak an equal opportunity
employer because you treated everybody
equally bad it's not my ideal employer
but how is that gonna impact different
groups disp report on Houston
indiscriminate use a language that I
think you will understand right now yeah
indeed there are look this one is where
this works in countries where
pescetarian ISM and vegetarianism has
become a cultural phenomenon this chap
the founder of this company sitting in
his Silicon Valley home he's about to
build a multi-million dollar mansion on
a mountaintop in Utah you know these
people advising houses flown into him
right and on a carbon footprint by the
way in that mountaintop he's gonna have
sushi flown into him and have all these
vegetables flown in meanwhile I imagine
he operates in Mexico I imagine he
operates in you know less well developed
countries where culturally and
financially they cannot afford the sort
of diet that he on his high mountain yes
he's pontificating over to use your
language it's a level of Western
cultural colonizing nice that is nice
truck to the point is
we work if paying for the food there's
an about discrimination because when
they go buy whatever they are there's
going to be a difference to be a
difference between the company picnic
when the company is entitled to provide
whatever food it wants to provide and
say expenses someone's flown somewhere
it's gone out for dinner surely they're
entitled to choose what they want to
will of course I don't work somewhere
where people pay for me to go and have
dinner luxurious viola I've never
expensed a meal we do not know the
problem on sushi enjoyed by this
particular gentleman or how its apply so
we just want to make that away and we
need to see what do we work co-founder
Miguel McKelvey says about this quotes
new research indicates that avoiding
meat is one of the biggest things an
individual can do to reduce their
personal environmental impact even more
than switching to a hybrid car this
policy only applies to events paid for
by we work members and employees are
welcome to bring in meat for meals and
members are welcome to serve meat at
events they host well I know what I'm
doing I'm setting up a barbecue in the
car they have an annual festival a
members festival it's 309 pounds for a
ticket and go along there's music and
there's food included if I go to a
festival I want a cheeseburger and chips
when I get there that's my but don't
tell a bloke or a woman if there's been
all day fun are play around the world
they kind of a bacon sandwich to retreat
a bit from my hyperbole it is true that
meat eating leaves a huge acknowledge
I've got to me a cop I want to
acknowledge that actually as a meat
eater I'm more responsible than a
vegetarian or a pescetarian
let me just give you the stat I wish I
didn't a percent like calories consumes
come from meat and dairy so 18% of our
calories but 83% of farmland and 60% of
Agriculture latest greenhouse you know
what the problem with that for me and I
thought I was I'm not vegan now but I
was vegan for years and I was a raw food
vegan as well which is what did you I do
and I kind of you on that and also
things like nuts require a huge amount
of water so the idea that kind of nut
milks instead of dairy milk is really
violently friendly and as you know this
is someone who hates a lot saw when I
was vegan that also can contribute to
the destruction of all stop eating beef
cows will die out it's not ideal but I
think we need to be thinking a lot more
conscientiously that's true isn't if we
stopped eating beef cows we actually
become extinct with the comic gear
because it can't survive alone when we
invented our horses didn't become
extinct we just have bothered you so
breed horses very far fewer horses than
there were cows for hosting I wouldn't
have a problem with we were hosting
afternoon lunchtime sessions where they
try to educate people about veganism or
vegetarianism I don't have a problem if
you want to educate people into that and
allow you to make a choice fine but
telling people no you can't eat that on
our money okay so if I take a client out
for dinner so I'm trying to get a you
know wine and dine a landlord because I
want to do a business deal with him and
we go to a restaurant and he wants a
lasagna well if I gotta pay for his
lasagna because the odd waiter said to
my client you've been on wife to wife
the Guardian which I don't anymore I
could have to explain something sit them
out I can't order you champagne and I've
had some bizarre debate over the last
two years but this has to be the plot if
it wasn't viewer who would defend to me
and Michelle
I knew this debate was coming when you
tweeted a picture michelle tweeted a
picture of a vegetarian sausage she was
eating and and
some other stuff that companies are
doing that is good but I got on a train
and for the first time in my life I
thought I'm gonna go for the veggie
optos look bad boy I've got a sausage
and some potatoes yeah I took a picture
of it I was about to take my first bite
of it and then there was announcement
we've changed the destination of this
train it's now going into wherever
everyone needs to get off I don't even
have a bag of it well the two connected
somehow sausage of the train being done
here - no there was someone up there
telling you some sounds like a blasphemy
- order